so the first story we have is an update
what's happening with mike lindell this
story was crazy it broke last night you
know we're sitting here trying to do
this show i'm trying to talk about ariel
because the new movie she she's black
and there's a big controversy and then
all of a sudden luke is like breaking
news we gotta check it out mike lindell
had his phone seized by the fbi so we
have some updates
post millennial reports the search
warrant shows mike lindell phone seized
in identity theft damage of protected
computer investigation the search
warrant for the phone seizure reveals
that it was taken over an identity
identity theft and damage okay they're
just repeating themselves they say uh we
know this
documents posted by lindell reveal the
reported reasoning with a page titled
items to be seized reading that the
physical cellular telephone assigned
number redacted
lindell cell phone and all records and
information on the lindell cell phone
that constitutes fruits evidence or
instrument instrumentalities of identity
theft as well as intentional damage to a
protected computer and or a conspiracy
to commit identity theft and or to cause
intentional damage to a protected
computer
that's just crazy i was talking to a guy
earlier today
regular guy you know just a regular guy
and he said how are they getting away
with this
how did they go after what 40 subpoenas
tarting trump allies
and i i just want to add to that
you'd think i mean we're going on what
year seven of hoaxes targeting trump and
his allies
how does this keep happening why hasn't
it stopped it seems to be getting worse
but um we're lucky enough to have uh you
know you uh devin and derek seem
seemingly the experts on this on what's
going on so
you tell me man how do they keep doing
this how is it how are they getting away
with it you know what's interesting
about lindell especially is that he's a
brilliant guy i don't know if he's ever
been on your show before but he's
absolutely brilliant he's a brilliant
marketer
and passionate guy
and he's the freaking my pillow guy
i mean he's just he's funny everybody
knows who he is because he's been on tv
for so long
but i will tell you that
this is this actually really happened so
i don't want people think that i'm
really i'm a fbi informant but
i was talking to him
just in the last i don't know about
about a week ago and i was i was
laughing so i was actually just trying
to get some pointers on true social
because we're
we're beginning advertising
and i asked him you know you know
because he always wants to talk about
election issues which is which is fine i
mean he's very passionate about it
and we were talking about the january 6
commission and you know how you know i
had said look what i've said from the
very beginning of that is is that you
know writing's not okay breaking in the
capital is not okay but where's the 14
000 hours of videotape and he tells me
you know that i've never gotten this is
what mike liddell told me just just a
week ago
and i'm paraphrasing but i've never
been contacted by anyone
for any of this you know for all the
stuff that he's that he said out there
so
and then
just he shouldn't went to that hardy
site right hearties
well tim trying to answer your question
here the first thing i thought about was
in 2017 on msnbc chuck schumer went on
national television and said that the
intelligence agencies have quote six
waves from sunday to get back at you and
he was hinting at the intelligence
agencies doing a revenge plot against
donald trump do you think there's some
merit to this especially from your
information from the inside that there
that this is the intelligence agencies
heading back against trump with the
battles that were happening within the
white house well they were already
weaponized
so when schumer says that remember so he
probably already knows because it was
the democratic party clinton campaign
that paid for this whole operation that
probably started in 2015 so schumer
probably already knows when he makes
that very
infamous statement that you know of
course is seen by
30 40 percent of the country but the
rest of the country doesn't know it
exists also i would just
what are the things that the fbi has
chosen not to do i mean they're looking
at identity theft and putting resources
into that when they didn't touch the
hunter biden
laptop
they didn't look at the thousands of
assaults on federal officers in portland
and other places during 2020.
the chinese they're pulled back from
investigating chinese financial crimes
and ripping off billions of dollars from
american individual investors i mean one
could go on the maxwell client list i
could go on too so yeah absolutely i
just needed to interrupt you sorry go
ahead i mean well i'm only here
for because i know that there's one
person at this table that's been to
epstein island
that's correct
[Laughter]
so i love introducing luke to people and
i'm like he's been epstein island
and then everyone just gives him this
look like
what was it like what was it like creepy
extremely creepy very
i was sweating running around trying to
videotape as much as i could very bad
juju very bad energy just to clarify
stormed the island after the fact to
film and document what you know was
there
not he was not an invited guest yes an
amphibious assault yeah that's right ran
out of there got chased out but you got
to see the look on people's faces when
i'm like oh look spin epstein island
and i don't
anyway so you're a democrat all the
democrats visited there not always i
mean there were i mean if you look at a
lot of the people it's bipartisan when
it comes to the larger trafficking and
extortion operation that was pretty much
run by epstein a lot of republicans a
lot of democrats i mean a lot of people
intricately involved in our current
political system even trump appointees
that had to resign because of them
giving the sweetheart deal to of course
epstein and
and letting him get away from for
horrible horrible crimes and the fbi
also most notably was interviewing
victims of of his all the way in the 90s
and the fbi chose to ignore the victims
not help the victims that were coming
forward as police officers federal
agents prosecutors were all looking away
and and essentially aiding and abetting
into what was was hurting children in
unspeakable ways that we can't even
describe here on this broadcast so we
have a pattern here absolutely if you
look at the gymnastic investigation that
went nowhere too exactly and the client
list still wasn't released and glenn
maxwell went down for a crime where she
had no clients you know which is
absolutely mind-boggling
she was just like trafficking kids into
like a boat and then kicking out the
water and walking away
but we could talk about intelligence
agency corruption all day i think it's
interesting to see what's happening from
the inside especially from the
intelligence committees that's why you
know i asked you without that question
how this is playing out what's happening
here is
what do you think is the motive here is
it legitimately investigating a crime or
do you think this is
something bigger something something
more of a conspiracy yeah i don't know
how you know we can get into this right
now maybe talk about it later too but
we thought at least when when we
unraveled the russia hoax at the very
beginning so we're talking 2017 and 18
we thought at that point
that we had been able to
effectively
kind of solder the the wound stop the
bleeding you know molar the molar
nonsense with heart with um
his top lawyer uh andrew wiseman we
thought okay we stopped all that barr
came in durham came in
and i'm sure we'll get to the durham
investigation at some point too
but
we thought at least the lovebirds were
gone struck page all of that and ray was
at least saying the right things that
there'll be some healing period we're
trying to do everything right he always
said the right things but clearly what
it what has happened is that there has
been a
a gestapo like get trump crew that's
been created
within the national security division
of the department of justice and the fbi
and look we kind of know that now
because if you were involved in the
russia hoax the pre-planning and the
implementation in 15 and 16 you now got
a promotion and you're at the top levels
of the department of justice right now
so so that really happened and then you
know this whole
tbu guy that came out that was escorted
out a couple weeks ago fbi guy
you know he what they're doing is
they're running it with the national
security division and this and this is
important for the audience to know
there's a division in there called
counter intelligence
and
the way the rules and the regs work is
within counter intelligence they're able
to wall everything everybody off within
the fbi dha say oh counter intelligence
investigation can't talk about it you
know and that's how they effectively hid
a lot of this from us
which i will probably get into this
later but that's why i made the joke at
the outset this is why they brought dan
chenko who was the
fake phony russian source for the
dossier it's why the fbi brought him in
was to hide him from congress hide him
from our investigation you know what
your biggest challenge is
there is so much to understand to
unravel everything that's happening
that the average person can't absorb it
in a few minutes right you know that's
why i came on the show because it's like
two hours plus two hours so we'll just
get a list of names we'll go through it
we'll give everyone's bio have you ever
seen those crazy maps like the charts i
was just going to say let's get the
bulletin board out there and the plants
right now
has like a full-blown poster of this
thing with all the players wow
the crime web with the red red yarn or
whatever oh yeah it's actually quite
good and it's important to understand
it's not just the fbi here as you
mentioned but the fbi also influencing
the corporate media and large
institutions like wikipedia and the
washington post that were playing
defense for the intelligence agencies
regurgitating everything they were
saying criticizing attacking you for
calling out the clear lies clearing out
and then also journalists i was listed
on a washington post uh story as as fake
russian news because i didn't believe
i wanted to see evidence of this russian
collusion i said okay if you think that
there was russian collusion let's let's
present us with some evidence but we
can't believe the intelligence agencies
since of course they lie routinely to
the american people they lied about wmds
they lied about so many different things
that i could mention here iran contra we
could actually keep going on and on and
on and i was like there's no reason to
believe these guys because of that i was
on a list i was ostracized and i was
de-personed from wikipedia for even
asking questions well now what they've
become very good at is they just control
the whole process so you know not too
far away from here uh in you know in the
washington dc beltway it's become bigger
and bigger and bigger and colonel harvey
can tell you
that that's been probably the biggest
downfall we created this this new
superstructure after 9 11. we brought a
lot more bureaucracy in a lot more
bureaucrats and we're so much less
focused on
actually you know finding and taking
care of of hard targets that are
definitely a danger in the united states
and everything can now be manipulated
because remember the quick answer for
everything now is
we're going to have a dni do a report
well of course if it's a report that
supports the the democrats or the left
it always comes out exactly the way that
they want it to come out and of course
if it's a report that
actually goes after the democrats for
their you know whatever it may be like
for the rush oaks for example it took
the inspector general two years to come
out with this then it took durham to be
appointed and now durham's had two
indictments and now we're still waiting
yeah there was a new york times article
about that today saying that the durham
report is not going to lead to anything
substantial do you think the new york
times perspective on it is correct or
would you question that new article that
just came out i don't know if you're
aware of the article well i don't read
fake news
and so i i actually don't even push on
you know the websites except you know if
they attack me
then i'll evaluate it and and see what
it is but but look i've actually
and colonel harvey maybe has a different
opinion than me but
i've actually been very supportive of
the durham investigation because it's
the only investigation that i've seen in
my entire two decades that i spent in
washington
with zero leaks
and that gives me quite a bit of
confidence and he's
and he's got to a lot of information
that we didn't even get to
one of the things the new york times
gets its information from fbi sources
the fbi uses the new york times
washington post they put a story out
there and then they use that story in
the new york times
to start an investigation it's amazing
absolutely and it's it goes like that
and there's that relationship
you guys talk about it all the time on
the show you guys talk about narrative
building yeah oh yeah yeah yeah that's
all it is it's amen
i'm interested to see what happens with
the durham investigation but i got to be
honest it's taken so long we haven't
seen a whole lot that
i don't know i don't have a lot of faith
but i wonder
if maybe the reason we're seeing them go
so heavily now after trump allies these
40 subpoenas could it be because they're
worried they're running out of time well
look if you want to let's talk about the
mar-a-lago raid because you know all
roads you can give you know keep it
simple all roads basically lead back to
russia gate i mean pretty much all roads
lead to russiagate right even the
impeachment hoax on you know on ukraine
was still russiagate same players so if
if you've had cash patel on the on this
show before
so the one thing that we learned
throughout our investigation is is that
the
fbi doj they love to use fake news
to
go into their affidavits into their
warrants
well
the first thing i noticed when i read
that affidavit and you know the
inspector general has said you shouldn't
do it and then when that when the when
they released the warrant and the
affidavit
there was two stories essentially that
was all that was the only thing
unredacted were two news stories now
i've never seen fbi doj in all my time
ever use a breitbart story right because
they consider breitbart to be fake news
but for the first time in my life they
used breitbart right
and in it was cash patel
and cash patel they completely take what
he says out of context what he says is
that he's seen the intelligence reports
relating to the russia hoax that were
that were declassified and we've never
seen
they basically misconstrue that we don't
see everything below it but what cash is
clearly talking about there is he's
talking about
the documents that i've seen derek seen
we've all seen we didn't see him at
mar-a-lago we saw him when we were in
congress or we were at the they were you
know
or at the white house we saw all those
documents they're supposed to be
declassified they're using that out of
context they're using to just to play
these games
and the other story of course was a
local news agency that saw some white
vans pull into monologue
yeah yeah moving boxes or something yes
back to durham real quick
tim you know i i worry that durham is
going after people like deshenko and
kleinsmith for false
document
issues but he's not going to go after
the root of the problem which is in the
fbi itself
the trump sleeper cell
or maybe not it's the national security
division yeah and
they're enablers over at the doj
how worried should we be i mean are we
gonna see republicans win in november
then maybe do something about this or
are they not going to do anything until
the executive branch changes
look i i think for the first time
uh that i've seen people are really
pissed off
out there i mean just you know if i
travel across the country and you see it
i mean people are really really
concerned and they should be i mean i
would have never i can't say that it
that it shocked me
that they raided mar-a-lago
but man this is really banana republic
time thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you